pour pour cette dernière journée
normalement ouais enfin je crois pas que
ça puisse durer plus non je crois pas
non plus mais bon qui c'est qui c'est
est-ce que ambulant peut revenir pour
une super finale où il te dit en fait
bah non je suis de retour je rejoue bah
pourquoi pas en fait en même temps
normalement c'était le favori quoi donc
ça pourra donner une grande finale là
bon celle-là pour l'instant elle est un
petit peu à sens unique mais écoute ça
peut tourner imagine ça ne gagne cette
partie il y a plus qu'un point d'avance
ce petit coup de stress et c'est bon
jamais non c'était parler au téléphone
et on pensait la petite berlinoise e4-5
mais en fait non ça part sur des quatre
il refait G6 bah écoute c'est à dire que
Sarine est venu au combat alors
son nom soyez venu au combat oui mais
j'ai vu son interview d'après match hier
bon alors il a annoncé la couleur
tu vas être très solide il a ils lui ont
dit oui machin tu dois marquer un point
un point et demi demain nanani nanana
lui moi j'espère faire trois nuls enfin
bon
mais il a bien raison normal
j'ai vu dans l'autre sens avec des
damacates pour t'empêcher de reprendre
du pion ça va l'énerver ça tu penses que
les joueurs peuvent avoir eu des
consignes de range qui leur dit bon les
gars
stop faire nul trop vite l'organisateur
il espère qu'il est toujours beaucoup de
combat mais le problème en fait c'est
que les joueurs sont là pour gagner pas
pour faire le spectacle non non je sais
mais genre c'est propositions nulles un
petit peu intempestives est-ce que tu
penses qu'il a dit fin tu vois les gars
si vous pouviez un peu qu'est-ce que tu
veux y faire en fait soit tu mets des
règles avant de tournoi interdit aux nul
en moins de 30 coups interdit aux
proposition de nul tout court ou et puis
bah si annule c'est dans les positions
complètement nulles des finales qui sont
nuls quoi ou trois fois la répétition
autre problème position et là peut-être
qu'il a pu dire un petit mot mais
[Musique]
j'ai même envie d'aller plus loin femme
et te dire que finalement hier sur sa
deuxième partie avec les Blancs alors
qui menait déjà d'un point c'est lui qui
a ouvert le jeu en réalité en sacrifiant
la qualité si on réfléchit bien
complètement alors qu'il était pas
obligé d'ailleurs j'ai toujours pas
compris mais
en tout cas celui à porter bonheur et
voilà il a peut-être senti une petite
fragilité en face probablement et bah
c'était choisi un choix payant de sa
part mais j'ai envie de dire là autant
parfois on peut le critiquer sur le fait
qu'il ferme le jeu autant là la
quatrième partie bah il fait nul avec
les Noirs mais bon on a du mal à lui
demander plus une rapide et la deuxième
il était mieux avec les dents j'ai
toujours du mal à critiquer le joueur
avec les Noirs quand il fait nul
rapidement parce que c'est ce que tu es
venu chercher et alors quand tu fais la
nulle rapide avec les blancs dans la
berlinoise et que tu saches complètement
on peut dire bon on aurait préféré avoir
plus de jeux mais quand le joueur avec
les Noirs prend un légère avantage et
qui décide de gérer en prenant le demi
point il y a c'est quand même difficile
de enfin il obtient ce qu'il était venu
chercher quoi
de toute façon
en tout cas pour l'instant il gère bien
et donc il a choisi le A3 B4 en tout cas
pour rompre le clouage donc la lame
bouge il va reprendre les quatre du pion
bien sûr c'était pour ça qu'il a fait
tout ça c'est pas pour reprendre une
pièce il va mettre le fond B2
probablement après et développer
peut-être qu'il y a des dossiers 4 aussi
qui arrivera pour aller te regagner un
tempo sur la dame
mais en fait il va adapter selon la
structure qui en choisir si je joue avec
des 5 il fera autre chose peut-être bon
tu peux aller dans des deux ou on C3
mais peut-être direction C5 en fait dans
les deux cas là tu as un peu le choix
bon sûrement tu fais fouger deux déjà tu
rock et tu avisera après sur ton aile
dame j'imagine j'aime bien la position
des blancs personnellement cette prise
d'espace Fabien A3 B4 elle est elle est
quand même assez intéressante oui après
peut-être fougère ça va et je me dis
fougère deux il y a peut-être à 5 je
pensais exactement la même chose que toi
en même temps je vais te dire ici trois
d'abord à 5 ta B5 voilà donc plutôt que
ces trois du coup
case parce que rentrer à la maison bon
bah tu rentres à la maison en C7 tu es
quand même très exposé au fouet 4 au
tour 5 qui vont arriver donc en B6 c'est
peut-être le moindre mal bien que ce
soit loin d'être parfait je m'en suis
fait fouger de rock rapidement et je
pense aussi c'est jouer instantanément
D6 et rock ouais c'était forcément mieux
avec les Blancs ici enfin c'est un
discutable mieux développer plus
d'espace bah quand tu vas te faire tu
menaceras [ __ ] M6 qui est des seins
qui est premier
pour le noir mais bon
la turbine propose un enchaînement des 5
faut bouger fou trois fous des 4 le truc
c'est que sur des 5 et prends des 5 qui
prend des 5 fous prends des 5 dames en
des 5 fous prends un il y aurait fou 3 à
la fin et tout reprend et les pièces
noires vont être fatiguant en fait des
temps en plus tu gagnes un temps ici tu
vas en gagner un deuxième ici tu vas
mettre ta tour enceinte tu vas peut-être
en gagner un troisième ici un moment
donné tu auras encore cavalé des quatre
pour en regagner un là à un moment donné
tu as commencé à faire un peu trop de
temps non tu vas tu vas tuer des temps
sur toutes les pièces noires en fait bon
après ça dépend il n'a qu'une
philosophie de façon saut à être accepté
comme il est et il fait fou B2 plus que
l'autre bah viser la nul ça ne lui fait
pas peur
il a raison
toujours le point levé un petit coup
comme H3 pour essayer de préparer des 5
4 gagner le fou en force
ouverte tu te mets dessus quoi plus
logique toujours est-il donc
il fait pas grand chose mais pour
l'instant tout est en ordre bon du coup
on n'a pas énormément varié la partie
mais en fait c'est pas passé grand chose
donc
stratégie de jouer pour faire nul et il
y arrive il a bien tout échangé il y a
qui avait les fou chacun et plus que 4
pions symétrique en plus il va il va se
diriger tranquillement vers la nulle un
peu trop de pions sur noir à mon goût
mais oui ça va passer
H4 mais bon étant donné que tu as décalé
F4 qui rôde pour les
rh58 après c'est marrant il a pas joué
un coup pour gagner là [ __ ]
voilà il change encore un pion le jour
où il y aura plus de pions on sera plus
trop possible de gagner
c'est un bon conseil ça vous pouvez
avoir quand vous êtes devant niveau
matériel et changer les pièces mais pas
les pions
juste un fou de plus par exemple à la
fin ou vous ne pourrez plus gagner
un petit défi c'est magnifique
[Musique]
sans c'est pas passé grand chose dans
cette partie non non mais bon bah écoute
ok
cette partie on va voir il a bouffé
[Musique]
le surestime le pion de plus mettre sur
l'impression que je vais mater avec les
gens dans ces positions enfin j'en suis
toujours absolument convaincu et
achèterait souvent je mate pas et je
suis toujours aussi surpris c'est pas
facile quoi
j'ai le fou j'ai le cahier j'ai la dame
bon ben c'est mat quoi
mais c'était j'ai un biais cognitif dans
ce truc là et je le sais mais ça
m'empêche pas de tout le temps être
choqué quoi
je pense qu'il faut faire juste
tout non c'est tellement le scénario de
toutes mes parties dans cette structure
je pense que je vais faire mal c'est un
coup j'ai plus de pièces quoi
mais là je suis encore très confiant là
j'ai encore les cases morts autour du
roi donc là ça va encore lâcher encore à
deux doigts de maths mais là
généralement je dirais bon heureusement
que j'ai le pion H4 et tout ce que c'est
un peu plus compliqué que prévu quoi
mais je reste très confiant généralement
et quelques trucs
[Musique]
prendre des trois temps après
mais bon
en maths quoi en tout cas si sauvegagne
le tournoi est déjà terminé exactement
exactement ça peut parce que de toute
façon autant faire au lit pour pour ça
peut-être prendre deux trois prendre des
trois telines de pièces et bah c'est ce
qu'il est en train de faire c'est pas
mal donc dame prend c'est pas la logique
parce qu'il y a pas de découverte avec
le footclasse blanche puisqu'il y a qui
allait prendre un donc on peut pas donc
dame prend 3 ça semble logique façon
plus ça redirige la dame en direction de
H6 après peut-être qu'ils sont JAF donc
ça a l'air d'être un coup absolument
horrible visuellement mais au moins ça
ouvre la Tour Eiffel
je veux dire c'est pas un coup pour
faire nul de me prendre non non non mais
bon enfin je rêve France et bon ça sans
visage quoi exactement
après une fois que tu vas commencer à te
changer les tours réelles et qui va
rester plus que les pièces mineures et
le fou pour couvrir les cases noires il
va suffire hein on a réussi à faire avec
un Mini's damage 6 puis kg 5 réussir à
récup le fou il faudrait peut-être faire
damage 6 ou F4 qui est G5 reprendre du
Fou aller vers FC c'est maté ça ça peut
être un plan mais bon ce sera quand même
dur s'il faudra pas se prendre à ce
moment-là après foule que le four
reprenne en G5 un dam prend E5 et dames
G7 qui viendrait tout couvrir avec deux
pions de plus ouais non c'est vraiment
dur de faire mat
pas simple
[Musique]
alors que je serai complètement sûr que
je suis gagnant
à chaque fois je regarde la liste de
party encore raté un truc quoi
[Musique]
mais après ça reste plus simple à jouer
en pratique toi tes pièces et à l'autre
de trouver ses défenses quoi
la jauge ça fera un petit peu mais
logiquement parce que du coup la chose
elle veut prendre maintenant des 8 en
des trois pardon et mettre la tour en D8
et du coup on a gagné un peu le tempo
qu'on voulait gagner après son plan
c'est jaillir vers F6 c'est bien joué
hein
[Musique]
cavaliers C4 d'amf4
mais non
et tu reprends D4 et fous c'est juste
hors D8 mais ok ça c'est pas
aller vers là-bas ouais donc en fait
mais c'est pas du tout non
pas trouvé il a pas trouvé ce que
j'allais dire bon lui il joue pour qu'il
y ait des quatre qui est F5 il se
revient vers les cases pour tenir loin
et cavaliers des 4 cavalier F6 mais tour
des cartes j'ai bien aimé le ah c'est
joli mais c'était vraiment dur hein
je pense que c'est ce qu'il veut non
mais c'est sûr qu'il va faire c'est sûr
je sais pas on n'est jamais sûr de rien
mais qui a eu des quatre ça semble
clairement être son idée
c'est bien défendu quand même non mais
pour l'instant logique de part et
d'autre ça peut proposer nul à tout
moment là côté Wesley pour troll une
petite nulle pour avoir une partie de
plus là c'est roi G7 évidemment je pense
ouais c'est terrible cavalier en F5 qui
va blinder qu'est-ce qu'il a bien joué
Wesley c'est un modèle hein
après c'est sûr qu'on va attendre au
tour précédent qui a un peu un profil à
la Sarine bon de loin mais juste 150
points à l'eau de plus c'est vrai que ça
sentait bon quand même c'est je sais pas
tu as battu Nadal en demi et en finale
bon tu joues Kareno Busta à
Roland-Garros ouais ouais ça fait quand
même plus plaisir tu dis si c'est pas
assez contrat carenobusta en fond de
court
on devrait tenir quand même
un truc il veut H5 G4 je pense ouais bon
je ferai quand de base parce que j'ai
envie de stabiliser mon
dame prend non c'est pas fini hein
ok il a trouvé un vrai un vrai challenge
après peut-être tu fais tout reprendre
un tour des vies c'est
exacts comme ça si t'as plus la danse et
ça tu pourras prendre F6 enfin
il va décaler d'ailleurs mais bon du
coup c'est à ton avantage quand même tu
as échangé et peut-être tu as des tours
des quatre à ce moment-là et compagnie
ouais
bon il veut menacer juste faut prendre
F6 mécaniquement puis on prend un point
F4 c'est bien joué aussi soit défendre
le fou soit l'enlever de là
ou enlever le cavalier mais du coup on
aimait bien investisse comme enlever le
fond en plus ça pas trop de cases si tu
vas quelque part c'est H2 mais
clairement c'est une concession tu te
bloques le roi tu te remets dans ton D8
qui menacera maths et en plus une fois
le temps une fois que tu donnes un peu
plus de fou pour F6 ouais donc il y a eu
4 je trouve bien joué aussi il recule
mais pour revenir quoi reculer pour
mieux sauter je pense
pas trop si vous perdiez le pion de 5
ouais
revenir quand même une fois un moment tu
as envie de tout échanger on va essayer
qui a l'air hyper tranquille hyper
serein après ouais peut-être il va
vouloir mettre un Caillon de 6 alors bon
vous faites un truc comme ça
ok bien joué
extrêmement confiance pour les Noirs la
jauge à plus hein
c'est pas aussi gagnant que ce qu'elle
dit il a raison mais c'est n'importe
quoi sa ligne c'est G5 fois H2 qui prend
des 6 puis on prend des six vous prend
des 6 dames des trois faut prendre H2S
c'est juste que nous on va pas avoir
parce qu'on est deux cons mais
d'ailleurs ils ont tous les deux et là
si tu as GF tu as mal d'amitié
7 8 mg8 ouais
mais peut-être que tu as même un fouet 6
qui va rouler beaucoup de merde comme ça
je sais pas trop grand tu vois mais les
gens qui disent choquent non c'est pas
un choc de NiAl
de toute façon j'ai écouté
sur deux quand on a pas gagné on s'y
party tu dis c'est maintenant jamais
j'ai l'attaque bon après ça défend bien
en face ça défendra bien il va faire de
la musique
enfin moi j'aurais fait exactement la
même chose que lui là de toute façon et
puis en plus tu as pas spécialement
envie je vais te dire d'en rejoindre une
de plus si tu fais nul
enfin
c'est terminé
ciao ça va se finir là normalement
trop solide le mur saut et bravo à lui
il a retrouvé du poil de la bête
voilà
si tu veux faire
ces derniers temps
noir il a su être très très solide quand
on a qu'à le faire fertile des et la
finale entièrement maîtrisée
la réfléchir là c'est du troll donc il
veut gagner la coquette somme de quoi
[Musique]
mais bien mérité il a été le meilleur
joueur sur ce tournoi sur cette phase
déjà qu'on travaille
très facilement
voilà si tu fais dameuse
propose d'échange et ça me prend HTC
prendre ma tante de enfin c'est pas
maths encore toi
et ça arrive à faire un bon tournoi oui
oui il a fait un bon tournoi
il pourrait être il pourrait être
content de son tournoi quand même
juste pas tomber quoi en fait
il était plutôt dominé contre guérit
mais guérit à craquer après bah tu
profites c'est comme ça ouais dans le
niveau de jeu il
a pas fait des des trucs de ouf mais il
assure il va gagner quand il fallait et
voilà bon là la finale
c'est pas trop mal ce qu'il a à le faire
ah bon ça y est c'est terminé
[Musique]
courte finalement hier il a déjà pris le
lit de deux points et il fallait tenter
quelque chose aujourd'hui il a tenté de
gagner dans les deux premières bah
écoute il est pas arrivé bravo c'est
comme ça après je la finale dure moins
longtemps que prévu c'est pas c'est pas
grave en soi on a eu du spectacle
surtout dans la demi-finale nakasso en
fait et la dernière partie c'était le
match le plus serré enfin tu vois même
si je sais pas j'ai pas eu la même
tension en fait Sonaca c'était vraiment
le match qui restera dans dans ton se
rappellera dans cette compétition
c'était la finale la réelle finale avant
l'heure trop facile pour ce haut qui est
extrêmement bien joué et bah écoute on
peut dire bravo à lui et quoi d'autre
bien sûr qu'on peut lui dire bravo on se
retrouve pour le speechers qui est une
belle compète merci encore mon frère
pour ce tournoi et à très bientôt ciao
bye